hello guys I'm Ryan right
hey guys I'm Veronica so my baby and I
are gonna check out today the boy the
official trailer number one I don't know
anything about it never do I I think a
girl from The Walking Dead's in it
really yeah well not fear not fear I
don't watch The Walking Dead we've had a
number of potential nannies come through
already
oh no you think you can manage of course
never good doctor hi I'm the grocery boy
well Corey man
lead the way allow me to introduce mr.
Yosh ah and this is our son wrong
music gives them so much joy bombs it's
not like at the children it is very
important that you follow these rules be
good to him and he'll be good to you
offense Brown sweet creepy
okay I needed someone else to say it see
what if you leave low it ography aside
this like some kind of magic trick right
so trick
Kohi well done we all Brahms it was
downright strange you've gotten town
used to come here to play with bones
they found a body in the woods by the
time the police arrived the place was up
in flames
Brahms didn't make it out hello
no one's been on there for years it's
not safe in this house
your Santa's happening
we'll be good to him won't you
Wow Wow that looks really scary before
you and I got together we had a similar
thing but with a sex doll the sex doll
was just out of control there's
something about it that is kind of silly
because it is a doll and I'm just
imagining during the production than
having to reposition it all everywhere
and it being the antagonist
I can imagine that'd be pretty silly
back to my sex doll it was always if you
didn't have sex with this xtal
everything don't worry this sex doll
looked like you had a custom-made have
you ever had sex with a sex doll I had
sex with a woody the Pooh Bear doll
you've told me that one that's old news
well that was technically my sex doll
this movie it reminds me of films like
Annabelle and also I'm dead silence
which was about a bunch of puppets and
stuff it started off like this is so
cliche but then when it revealed that
the boy was a puppet or whatever the
hell it was doll a doll that was really
creepy I don't know I feel like the
trailer kind of gave away way too much
though like a lot of the suspense is
already ruined
yeah gave away a lot of the fun yeah I
agree cuz they basically told us the
whole story it basically how he came
about how he came about a bunch of the
scares were gonna happen how crazy was
gonna get yes so now I feel like I'll be
sitting through this movie going okay
ones that other [ __ ] that I saw on the
trailer are gonna be happening you know
a bunch of the craziness her being
thrown around the hand through the
portrait yeah it looks like it could be
fun though I like that main actress
she's she's really good in the walking
dead yeah I don't I don't reckon
nicer you don't recognize she seems good
though she seems like a good actress do
you find her attractive she's okay just
okay why do you find her attractive
let's move on I would just love to pull
this as a prank on someone like make a
list of things for my dolls like I like
my not your doll like something great
like sillier like my Joker cutout board
like your Bangor so my bong my bong or
um or my heroin needles oh like you got
to feed the heroin needles and you got
to use them roast the heroin needles
will stab you that's really disgusting
well that's just a part of life Veronica
no it should not be important well
that's a part of my life and I wish you
would accept the fact that I love drugs
okay I'm sorry one thing I'm wondering
if I could easily believe this is her
character in The Walking Dead eventually
becomes super badass who's like okay
zombie coming near me I'm just gonna
walk up to it and stab it in the head
you know or she'll take on multiple
zombies and stuff I feel like this is
one doll she could take care of this
doll I've seen a whole show where she is
clearly kicking a bunch of zombies asses
this one doll you can take care of yeah
but that's not fair for the actress
because she's playing a completely
different character she does not live in
a world with zombies that's fair but
it's kind of like Jeremy Renner and
Mission Impossible rogue nation yeah
where you're like okay I saw that that's
Duke and kick-ass yeah why isn't he
kicking ass in this yeah okay I felt
that too and I watched that yeah so it's
kind that's kind of the impression I get
from this but then he does kick ass
though over talking my mission
impossible wasn't that what we're
talking about that is what we were
talking about yes you are correct I mean
this genre is very familiar to her she
was in Supernatural she was also in
Vampire Diaries and then she's in the
walking dead so she is good at this
genre she could be like a feature screen
Queen that's so cool I wonder how she
was able to get gigs for all these
fantasy films fantasy horror flicks yeah
I'm not sure if she's mainly from
television but it's cool to see that
she's finally got a
role in a film that a lot of people are
pumped up about yeah I know it's like to
pump a thing up you know I had to pump
up that doll don't worry
like I said look like you it was really
beautiful I did all kinds of position
positions you are not willing to do in
real life
excuse me yeah there are positions you
are not willing to do in real life
why don't you just have that doll bench
and I'll be on my way how would how
would that make you feel me do you think
I got rid of the doll yeah that's
disgusting
no the dolls in the closet yeah get good
at the hell out of this apartment no
I'll show you the doll when we're done
filming if you guys are new the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and become a reject a bot today people
like that one yet Veronica up on the
Veronica six Tests Channel acoustic
covers vlogs originals
[ __ ] and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine periscope shout
out to a [ __ ] let's do this
the peel Allah hi Ryan and all rejects
I'm from Finland and I've been watching
your channel for a while and I think I
went through all your videos like in
three days and yeah like you went
through all our videos that's about ten
to twelve hours per day if you did you
really inspired me to thinking to make
my own reactor channel that's great
there's not enough of those out there
just have to find the courage to do it
we are much alike even thousand miles
between i watch youtube videos daily and
for hours i play a lot of games and i
watch much well you know what and we all
have almost exactly the same vulgar
humor
he watches much you know what porn he's
talking about porn there's like 500
smiley faces in this comment that way
please give me a shout and be like
[ __ ] be crazy peace dude Tapio
[ __ ] be crazy [ __ ] are always
crazy I mean Veronica come back for this
crazy [ __ ] she's a crazy [ __ ] in a
Tapio eleda that's actually a sex
position oh is it
that's where you dip your balls in the
girl's mouth and then um she jerks you
off at the same time and then she
fingers you and you take a [ __ ] while
while she's sucking on your balls and
then you turn around and then you fart
on her face and then she put her head in
the [ __ ] then you kick her a few times
how dare you kick her if you had on its
tappy oh he's a sick [ __ ]
she wasn't [ __ ] about him a sex doll
how dare you talk to me like that what
are you talking about I don't want to do
that to you oh you're the crazy that in
front of me that's disgusting
all of that is disgusting come here get
your [ __ ] hands off for me come here
oh no that was really gross oh no he's
horny as I am no no I'm not playing
hard-to-get
I like it I like it a little cat and
mouse game we got going on
see